hi
i'm everett white and welcome to deep
coverage our partnership with the
athletic
thanks for being here week one of the
nfl season is in the books and minus the
lack of fans
the piped in crowd noise the active
distancing and the nfl social push
the games have been pretty
indistinguishable from a normal season
the challenges though of holding a
professional football season during a
pandemic still stand
to talk about that and all the news
surrounding the revamp football season
amy trask joins us live she's an analyst
for the athletic
a contributor for cbs sports chairman of
the board of the big three basketball
league
and a form and former ceo of the now las
vegas raiders where she was the nfl's
first female
front office executive amy thanks so
much for joining us today how you doing
i am doing well and thank you for having
me it is an honor and a pleasure to chat
with you
i'm so happy to see you and glad to jump
into this conversation let's uh let's
jump right in
um so the first game is in the books um
and it's the first time players from
different areas are going to be
or are have been mingling all nfl
players and coaches passed their
cover tests last week and it seems like
they'll likely pass this week
amy as a former football executive what
safety concerns do you have going into
the second week
well i don't think anything changes
other than that which you just indicated
teams are traveling now and they are
mixing and mingling with others with
whom they haven't mixed and mingled
the league is doing a tremendous
tremendous job of
testing and tracing and limiting the
number of people on the sideline
and who are near the players and the
coaches masks are required on the
sideline the league actually sent out a
memo this week reminding everybody
pull your masks up if you're on the
sideline the league is doing
really all it can we don't control the
virus
but we do control the protocols and the
leak has put a number of terrific ones
in place
so cross your fingers that this
continues to work throughout the regular
season
and then perhaps the league should
consider in
bubbling for the postseason as mlb has
announced it will be doing
oh we'll get to that in a second for
sure but going back to the
the kind of safety concerns and and just
covered in general
what financial implications do you see
for the league the players and any
affiliated businesses and fans
if there isn't a bubble and what do you
see if there is a bubble
well a number of people have asked me
about the impact of no
fan or fan related revenues what does it
mean to the teams
that there are no fans in most stadiums
and in those stadiums which have allowed
or will be allowing fans will be a
reduced number
so that impacts ticket revenue club seat
revenue suite revenue concession revenue
parking revenue
any number of revenue streams and the
answer is
that will impact different teams
very differently because those revenues
constitute a
very different percentage of overall
revenues
for a number of the teams it is a very
significant portion for some
it is a less significant portion for
others and remember this one
thing ticket revenue itself is shared
between and among the teams so the home
team
when selling tickets i'm not talking
about suites or club seats or psl's but
the base ticket
keeps roughly two-thirds and the league
as a whole shares the other third
so the impact is split over the 32 teams
of that revenue stream
is there going to be an impact on
revenues of course there is
can the league survive this yes they can
oh great answer amy um so you mentioned
um that the mlb and the mlb's players
association agreed to have playoff
bubbles
um with daily testing that happened
yesterday and you wrote earlier in
september that the nfl should do the
same
though dr alan sills the nfl's chief
medical officer
said the league hadn't had no interest
in creating a bubble
what do you think of the mlb's decision
and does this make an nfl bubble more
likely and
i guess does do dr silze's words
have any bearing on how you feel about
that well thank you for noting with
respect to mlb that it was the mlb
and the players association that decided
this together because
you're so smart and thank you for doing
that because that would have to be the
same
for the national football league if
there is to be a playoff bubble it would
have to be
agreed to between and among the league
and the players association
look i wrote a few months ago for the
athletic
that a bubble for the regular season
would be
tremendously tremendously challenging
giving the number of teams
and the number of people who would have
to be in bubbled for each team
could it be done you know sure it could
be done we built a space station
we put men and women in space and they
live on this thing that's floating
around
so could there be a bubble sure but
would it be
very very very difficult to do it for
the regular season it would
what i proposed in my most recent
article on this topic for the league
of about a bubble for the league is that
the league should consider in
bubbling for the playoffs first of all
you'd be in bubbling a whole lot less
teams so it would be easier to do
and i went ahead and suggested what i
think is a terrific location for the
league to in bubble
for the postseason and that would be los
angeles and i articulated in that piece
why that's the case will the league
consider it
right now it doesn't appear so but if
the testing
doesn't continue to show the terrific
results it is
and if circumstances change as we get
closer to january
maybe the league and the players
association will consider this
we don't know what the world is going to
be like with respect to the virus in
january
um great answer as always amy and um
just wanted to make a note for our fans
that amy is the
originator of the term in bubbling um
you can look on urban dictionary right
now and you will see her name as
credited for it
so um give her her credit give her
flowers as she as she deserves
if i could jump through this screen
right now
and hug you which of course we can't do
because we wouldn't be distanced i
would hug you because i am very very
proud of that
it's a drop the mic moment for me and
bubbling is now in the urban dictionary
and if you don't think i'm telling my
nieces and nephews every day that their
aunt is in the urban dictionary
you don't know me very well i'm sure
they're proud i'm sure they're they're
really proud and showing all of their
friends
um going back to the the idea of a
playoff bubble you you said
that a regular season bubble would be
really difficult because of all the
sort of factors um you enlisted the
amount of players
and the the team personnel what other
factors go into
any sort of potential nfl bubble well
for
the league as a whole during the regular
season it really is math it's 32 teams
times let's say 150 it could be as low
as 100 it could be as high as 200
on average per team because you not only
have players you have coaches
trainers doctors equipment people
umpteen
personnel that are helping with the team
so let me just throw out a rough number
of 150.
you multiply that by 32 that's obviously
a lot more than if you multiply it
simply by the number of playoff eligible
teams
the other issue is stadium availability
for the playoffs if the league chooses
to in bubble and if they follow my
suggestion
of coming to los angeles there are a lot
of stadiums within
very very very close proximity so you
could in bubble here and have
all the games on different fields at
different times in a manner that
wouldn't chew up the turf too badly on
any one field
oh there's nothing worse than some shoot
up turf as you can probably
remember as as former raiders ceo um
and it's interesting you mentioned the
amount of different fields and
and facilities that la has it would be
very similar to
to the nba's bubble situation in orlando
where they're just a bunch of diff
different teams all sort of encased in
or in bubbled as you would say
in one um locale for for the
for a specific period of time but um
going back to
to your your your 10-year ceo with the
raiders so we're going to talk a little
bit about the social justice
aspect of nfl right now the washington
football team changed its name
the kansas city chief of amended their
fan conduct rules to be more sensitive
to native populations
and then many other teams are enacting
social justice initiatives specifically
around the black lives matter movement
how do you think the nfl has responded
to the call for social justice over the
past few months
well i'll touch on the washington issue
first i spoke out about that
publicly back in 2013 and i said
look i understand that if not all the
fans the vast majority of fans of the
washington team
didn't intend to say anything that would
be
harmful or hurtful but the fact is when
you open the dictionary
and look the word up it is defined
in the dictionary as a derogatory racial
slur
so back in 2013 when i started calling
for a name change
and i stopped well i had stopped saying
the name um a number of years before
that but i spoke publicly in 2013.
a lot of people gave me the side eye
like i was crazy
and now we see that there are
substantial changes being made and there
need to be so many
so many more changes i am old enough
that i remember very very well the
rodney king protests we had here in los
angeles roughly 30 years ago i was with
the raiders the raiders were in los
angeles and i really thought at the time
of those protests
okay now we're going to see change
effectuated
this is going to make a difference this
is going to help
and it didn't so here we are some
30 years later confronting the same
issues
and my hope is because so many of the
people involved now
not only players but in society in
general
they weren't even born 30 years ago when
those protests occurred
and they bring a certain i can only use
a french expression a
je ne sais quoi a strength a creativity
to helping with these problems that i
hope will do just that and help
and social media will help and the
manner we have of connecting with one
another
will help we can have conversations with
people throughout the world
in real time in a manner we couldn't do
30 years ago so i'm hopeful that all of
these things put together
mean the change that i had hoped and
believed we'd see
we would have seen 30 years ago we will
see now
as to the national football league um
they are
always going to be in the position in my
view where they are doing
more than some people think they should
be doing and they are doing
far less than some people think they
should be doing
they're going to have to continue to
navigate this and
i will quote someone from a movie do the
right thing
great movie and i'm sure spike lee is
watching and
proud that you quoted him um
sort of hearkening to your time with the
raiders what sorts of conversations
happen in front offices
when there is this push for social
justice initiatives
well i had a tremendous fortune that i
recognized
most people not only in the national
football league i'm talking business at
large
many people don't have the good fortune
i had i worked for a man
al davis who hired without regard to
race
gender ethnicity or any other
individuality which has
absolutely no bearing on whether one can
do
a job chronologically not in order
of importance of course chronologically
he hired tom flores
then he hired me then he hired art shell
this was not a one-off for al and he
didn't care about those individualities
race
gender ethnicity religion or anything
else that has no bearing on whether one
can do a job
so my point in sharing that with you is
the conversations
we were having that i was having with al
that we were having as an organization
were very different i am sure than the
conversations
many businesses throughout this country
are having
gotcha amen the raiders um historically
have been one of the more progressive
franchises in the nfl
um like you said al davis um hiring the
first black head coach the first latino
head coach and
obviously you the first female front
office executive
i'm going back to that oh i'm sorry um
given that this is bloomberg i will
share with you a theory that may have
people
rolling their eyes at me and that's okay
but it's what i call
business darwinism business it is my
belief and it is certainly my hope
that if there is such a thing as
business darwinism
that ultimately those businesses that
don't hire the way al did without regard
to those individualities that have no
bearing on whether one can do a job
will not succeed in the manner that
those
businesses who don't care about those
individuality succeed
and perhaps they'll fail because what
they are doing
by definition is eliminating vast swaths
of qualified people who can help their
businesses be better
so here's to business darwinism here's
to business darwinism and
we've certainly seen multiple studies on
and had reporting on bloomberg
showing that the more diverse an
organization is the better its outcomes
and and you would know tons about that
given the raiders illustrious history
um and you've definitely you've written
about it for your book um you negotiate
like a girl could you tell us about any
sort of
backroom dealings or war stories from
your time there i'm sure
al davis had a bunch of of just
you know moxie in the in the back
offices there in oakland and in las
vegas
and los angeles so many stories to tell
um i will share one and i'll try not to
cry on bloomberg
um but it is a moment that touched me um
it touched me deeply i i choke up when i
think about it to this day
we were having a meeting at our offices
and um
it was an important meeting we were
meeting with a business with whom i was
looking to make a deal
and i asked al to come to the meeting
and he did and he walked in and one of
the representatives of the business
which we were meeting was a woman and he
says to her oh it's nice to meet you i
want to let you know i try
very very very hard not to swear in
front of women
and i look at him and i look at all my
colleagues in the room like
did he just say he tries not to swear in
front of women that's my face
and he goes on and he says to her and
even if i do swear in front of you i
will never swear at you i don't swear at
women
and with this the pen i was holding in
my hand flew out landed on the desk with
a thump
and al looked at me and said oh and he
realized what i was thinking
and allowed to everyone he said oh
i swear at amy i don't consider her a
woman
and that was the highest compliment he
could have ever
given me that he didn't consider my
gender
when we were doing business and when he
hired me and when he advanced me
and when he cussed at me
no question did you swear back at him at
any point you you don't all
the time that's the biggest
misconception about al the biggest
misconception about al
is that he wouldn't tolerate
disagreement and he wouldn't tolerate
people who disagreed with him
if that were the case i would have been
fired roughly two weeks into my job
because we had a knock down drag out
fight and of course i don't mean
physically knock down drag out
i was sitting in the room with someone a
colleague al walked in and he ripped
into this man like i can only imagine a
velociraptor would have ripped into
flesh
and after a bit of time i realized al
was wrong
and i said to him excuse me you're wrong
i turned around and looked at me like
first of all you've been here two weeks
what what i'm wrong
and i said look if the facts on which
you were basing your conclusion were
correct
your conclusion would be fair but you
are basing your decision your conclusion
on inaccurate data and you're therefore
wrong
and he yelled and i yelled and there was
cussing
and after quite a bit of time he looked
at me and said okay
okay i gotcha and that was that and i
learned then
two weeks in that i could disagree with
al i could disagree with him vehemently
but if i was going to do so i needed to
come armed with
facts and i will tell you that over the
course of almost 30 years i disagreed
with him more than i agreed with him
and i'm sure um that you you know came
to
some very good conclusions and some very
bad conclusions in
that you know that time with the raiders
um and i'm sure you're excited to see
them
um taking off again in las vegas this
coming monday um
it'll be exciting to see that building
what's your prediction for the raider
season
you're already one enough boy i am sort
of yeah there's my prediction they're
going to win their first game how's that
of course we know they already did it
you know i'm not a good predictor as to
games i think what happens is i hearken
back to my years in the league
and i never liked to predict because i
felt that that was somewhat jinxy
so on cbs sports i am asked to predict
games
i will tell you that i was the only one
of
any of us on our pregame show last week
to pick seattle
to win its game and i'm going to be
gloating about that
the entire show this week well here's
hoping that your cbs um picks
all right again this week um but that's
going to wrap it up um
amy i'm so thankful i want to thank you
for taking the time to talk to us
i'm glad we got to learn a bit about how
an nfl front office operates during
such trying times and just um to get
your perspective on what it's like being
a woman
in an nfl front office it's it's
invaluable
and i'm just grateful to have had you
here well i thank you
uh the privilege and pleasure really and
truly was mine
i'm been a big big big bloomberg fan and
follower and as i mentioned
my husband's down on his bloomberg
terminal now so
thank you for having me this is a real
treat and now i've got some credibility
you know in the business world as well
uh well i'm sure he'll see this on his
terminal very very soon um
so uh thank you guys for joining us we
have amy trask here and i'm eric white
for deep coverage with quick take in the
athletic
bye guys